What's going on, folks? Welcome back to
another video here on the Mattv Vidpro
AI YouTube channel. There is plenty to
talk about today. We've got a little bit
of a news roundup, but the main thing
that is being talked about right now is
C Dance 2.0. This is a new video model
from Bite Dance, and it's nuts. I've
noticed that some AI models like runway
4.5 focus on trying to make things
cinematic or feel realistic, but Seance
2 here is more on the Sora 2 and V3 side
of things where it's about creating a
clip that stands in its own but also
theoretically could be used for longer
workflows. You can do things like upload
a comic and then have it transplanted
into a video immediately just from one
image. It's pretty insane. And a lot of
people are saying this is better than
Sora 2, better than V3. It is far less
censored. Let's look at some examples,
get a gist for what it can do, and then
I want to take it for a test drive.
Obviously, from this opening example,
you can see how good this model is for
animation and anime. These fight scenes
are super impressive. I don't think I've
seen any model do animated fight scenes
this well. I mean, it it's nuts. Out of
this world. Justin Moore shares this
video by Wild Busa. The model feels as
groundbreaking as photography. This clip
right here, guys, obviously going to be
a little bit more cinematic.
Wow. That's actually the first, you
know, type of photography that you could
do.
I got some weirdness going on.
>> I mean, the whole thing it it feels
cinema quality. The acting, the sound is
mindblowing. Like up at that Sora 2
grade quality. Smoke physics are
absolutely insane looking. And the fact
that it was able to render everything so
well. You could see salt, water, I think
iodine. There are certain moments in the
AI space where you see a model's output
and you just go, "Wow, okay. Yeah, we're
at a different level. This is this is a
new echelon." This is how I felt with
Sora, too. And this is this is a step
up, I think. Guys, look at these tight
action scenes.
Wow, this is seriously on another level.
You know, obviously there's still going
to be some hallucinations, but wow. Oh
my gosh. I don't even know what to say.
This one had a lot of hallucinations. I
think like right up here, it tries to
make sense of it, but there's some
armorphing and impossible movements for
sure. It's getting close to sussing
those out though. Like I had a Sora 2
generation that really blew my mind
recently, which I'll show you today
because we're going to be testing this
model out, getting hands-on. So Aiden
has a fight scene here that is combining
liveaction and anime. Very few movies
and things have tried this before. Not
easy for the AI to get right.
Wow. Whoa, dude. Okay, hang on. Well,
this whole place kind of looks CGI but
very realistic. This dude right here, he
absolutely looks real. But then she
comes out. It is absolutely hanging on
frames to give it an animated look here
for the entrance. And man, the quality
is nuts. Still following that rule here,
right? And it's a fully 2D character.
Like this would be drawn if it was real
anime, right? And that is a completely
3D realistic looking person. All right,
she charges up. They go in to fight. AI
is still hallucinating in certain areas.
as you can see fingers. But at this
point now she is 3D. She still looks
very much like a 2D character but you
know with the camera rotations following
the movement doing the action. You can
see especially on these scenes
completely 3D and that's like a real
glove too which I thought was
interesting. It's doing a lot of heavy
lifting here trying to figure out how to
actively convey the fight scene. And I
think it did a really great job. I've
seen Sora 2 kind of do stuff like this,
but not that coherent. Quick pit stop
before we continue the video. I've got a
quick word from today's sponsor. We talk
a lot about building things with AI on
this channel. But if you want to
understand how they actually work, you
need to break them. That's why we're
working with Try HackMe today. They are
the massive cyber security training
platform that teaches you by actually
doing. No 20inut installs, no breaking
your own PC. It all happens right here
in the browser. Let me show you a few
receipts. I'm in the offensive security
intro room right now. I've got a Linux
terminal spun up instantly. I'm going to
run a command called DURB. Basically, we
are brute forcing this fake banking
website to find hidden pages that aren't
on the menu. Boom. Look at that. It
found images. Boring. But wait, bank
deposit. That right there is a security
endpoint. Now, I could go there and show
you how to transfer fake money to your
account, but I'm going to leave that for
you to try. Here's the part that grabbed
me as someone on the pulse of AI. If you
get stuck, they have an AI tutor named
Ekko. It analyzes the specific task
you're working on and gives you guided
hints without just handing you the
answer. It's like having a senior
engineer sitting right next to you.
Whether you are informing yourself
casually or serious about a career in
cyber security, this right here is a
fantastic way to start learning handson.
You can start entirely for free. But if
you want the full experience, unlimited
fast machines, and all of the career
paths, I recommend you grab the premium
plan. Use code MVP25 for 25% off the
annual plan. The link is right at the
top of the description. Go hack a bank
legally and let me know how much money
you can siphon. Huge thanks to Try
Hackme for supporting the channel. Now,
back to your regularly scheduled
content. Welcome back, folks. Seance V2
offers a wide variety of aspect ratios.
This one's supposed to be a little bit
more old school, 4x3.
Insane. Really captures that old school
style.
Oh god, that creepy eyeball though. What
the [__] Why? It is important to point
out models like these still have
limitations. So Padphone ran a test with
the model. You can see there is a maze
and a duck is supposed to follow it, but
the duck clearly decides to avoid the
maze. There is intelligence there, but
it just has no problem making the duck
phase through walls. It's not smart
enough to understand our constraints at
that level and fulfill them. But other
models fail this too. I think V3 in this
example did a much worse job. All right,
so this is the website where we will be
getting access to Seance 2.0 by Bite
Dance. It's going to be linked down
below. I believe it's just called Bite
Dance Plus. You can log in with Google.
It's a nice website, especially compared
to a lot of the other Chinese video gen
sites. You can see they actually have a
ton of templates, things to kind of get
the gears turning in your mind or quick
things to try out. I want to try my own
stuff. It looks like we can reference
not only images, but images as
individual characters, backgrounds as
individual backgrounds, and also upload
videos and audio. This thing's fully
multimodal in. Oh, wow. Okay. No, I
actually can't upload any references
right now. We're going to have to raw
prompt this thing with just text tokens.
All right. So, this is going to be my
first prompt since we can't upload any
imagery or videos yet. This is a movie
scene. A criminal is hiding out in
Atlantis. The original prompt used me,
my cameo reference in Sora, but I've
modified it for a typical criminal.
You'll also see on the side here, this
is all the settings essentially at API
spec level, right? We have reference
generation, images, audio, video, and
then first and last frame for more total
control. I like that. I think that's a
good dichotomy there for the two modes.
Couple different aspect ratios. 21 to9
that's like film. 16 by9 that's this
video right now. 4x3 that's a little bit
more old school a square. 3x4 which is
kind of like a painting. And then 9x6
Tik Tok. You can also do smart aspect
ratio. You know what? I'm going to click
it on and leave it on smart. So the
model's going to decide. I guess we've
got 480p or 720p resolution. I like
those choices. That's about where we're
at with AI video generation. 1080p
you're not really gaining any
resolution. It's more like fake
resolution. Looks like the model goes up
to 15 seconds, similar to Sora 2. I'm
going to set it at smart length. The
prompt is asking for 15 seconds. All
right, you know what? This all looks
good. Let's send it on through. One of
the things I'm going to be looking out
for here is generation time. That is
huge for AI video. AI video takes a
while to generate images. I mean, that's
like almost instant, almost always under
a minute at this point. Ooh, accelerated
generation. We're already at 25%. Oh,
wow. Cue a video on Sora AI. It's going
to take a few minutes at least to get
that video back. All right, it's kind of
been hanging at 95%
for a while. All right, I got another
one I want to try to send through. Okay,
so nice. It lets me cue other prompts as
well. It looked like the video
generation was going very quick, but all
of a sudden now it is hanging. Okay,
well, while we wait for these
generations to go through, I want to
show you some that the community on
Discord have been making. This is the
more uncensored, open and free Sora 2
variant that we've all been waiting for.
It doesn't matter that it's not fully
open source. This is likely the highest
quality video model we have access to
right now. These are all from directly
inside my Discord server. So, if you
make anything cool, feel free to share
it here. All right. This first one is
from Snow Strider.
Wow, the audio is nuts, guys. If you're
wearing headphones, it's like direction
like you could feel it kind of come
closer to you as if it was really
recorded on, you know, someone's phone.
The microphone arrays that we have on
most modern phones these days are very
good. And wow, the audio feels very
realistic. But pay attention to the
footwork, guys. That's really the magic
allar on this one.
He's kicking the ball. It's kind of a
little hard to tell.
Yeah, he's kind of Yeah, that is an
insane one where it's like he clearly
there's a sound when the goalie touches
the ball, but it makes it past the
goalie. Another user, a little bee,
testing it out. Rick and Morty in Game
of Thrones. Tell me this doesn't remind
you of early Sora 2, but actually
better.
>> Behold, Morty, the Iron Throne, now with
90% less boring feudalism and 100% more
portal juice.
>> Uh, Rick, I don't think the locals are
too happy about that. Why is Beth just
here? Absolutely insane, though, how
clear the voice comes through. Look at
the details. The art style is so
spot-on. It's freaking creepy. Roro, who
has like 20,000 plus followers on Sora
2, tell you how good of a prompter they
are, generated this video,
dude. Whoa. This is actually insane. I'm
sorry. I'm freaking out because getting
to this level on Sora 2, it took time
back and forths.
Another
one from Snow Strider.
>> Unbelievable scenes here tonight.
Dude, whoa. I was like, "Yeah, most hits
are landing. The sound is consistent.
It's good." And then the slow-mo part,
like dude, movie level, bro.
Dude, what? Oh my god, I'm freaking
hype. All right, Lil Be's got some more
Rick and Morty.
>> Rick, what are those things? They're
monsters. We got to run.
>> Relax, Morty. They're just gambas. Watch
this.
Boom. Take that, primitive AI.
>> Gambas. For reference, guys, I was doing
Rick and Morty Generations with Sora 2
when it first came out.
>> Morty gum exists because of one man,
John Gum. Visionary, chewer, hero.
>> THAT'S NOT A REAL PERSON. NO ONE NAMED
JOHN GUM INVENTS GUM. THAT SOUNDS LIKE A
PUPPET MADE UP. THREE BOOKS ARE
>> You could tell the quality is more
shimmery. The audio is decent, but not
as good as what we just witnessed. The
hands are messed up. It's not as
coherent, but oh my god, Cance 2, it
fixes all of that.
>> Okay, fine. Doubting Morty, you want
proof? I'll get you proof. I'LL GET YOU
JOHN FREAKING GOING TO GO FIND A GUY
NAMED GUM. That's That's insane, Rick.
Insanely easy. Portal, couple of chewy
detours. Boom. History less like it's
not as honed in as sharpened. This is
Sora 2 Pro.
>> What the hell are you? Some candy BASED
CRYPTED SENTIENT WAD. I need nouns.
>> Rick, he's he's not real.
>> Am I hallucinating or something?
>> Name's John Gum. 100% real. 98% sugar.
Pleasure to meet you.
>> Just shed on my floor. Nobody real does
that.
>> THAT'S A REAL THING. SHED DOG, SNAKES,
CORPORATE FRIENDS.
>> HOWDY. OKAY,
>> it's good, but there's still
hallucinatory effects. I think Seance
2.0 is better than Sora 2 Pro, at least
for, you know, this Rick and Morty
testing. Another one coming in from
Whoosh.
Man, the audio is crazy. But it's the
fight scene as a whole. The whole thing
coming together. Look at the people
recording with their phones in the
background.
This one right here is from Godly
Steve versus Freddy, dude. And it's I
mean, it's doing it. Sure. Here's your
gen little bee's got more Rick and
Morty.
Whoa, wait, Rick. They're just They're
probably just lost or something.
See, Morty, easy. Now come on, let's go
beat this stupid game,
>> dude. Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh. Whoosh
said they cooked.
>> The legend is real. The Dragon Balls are
out there and we're going to find them.
>> Yeah, insane the adherence to the
animation. And again, the audio, it's
crazy. The audio is so good that you
forget it's there. Okay, this one by
Maddie is good.
I WANT A BIG MAC.
>> I'll have the royal platter. Make it
snappy. Bring me all your finest
offerings and I might spare this
establishment.
>> The kitchen is closed.
>> Oh my god. They walk up, you know, it's
very mundane. It's McDonald's clearly,
but also like anime in the same style as
the rest of the characters. They try to
get food, you know, he threatens her.
It's professional level audio, dude. I
swear. Once she says they're closed
though, he freaks out. I love that anime
reaction. So authentic. And then he
poofs away, which is just hilarious. And
he just puts his head down. It's good,
man. Whoosh. Showing off a Cartman Jen.
>> I'm the best duelist there is. My
blue-eyed white dragon IS GOING TO WIPE
THE FLOOR WITH YOU. Egg T.
I won't let you win, Cartman. I'm going
to fight for
>> Look at the texture.
This is a next level model, dude. This
is a step up. Oh god. User Robnog has
brought my Twitter profile picture to
life.
>> I see a girlfriend.
>> I think it's supposed to be like a
a lemon girlfriend. They captured me
well though with the full lemon suit. I
love it. Disgusting and weird. Mr. Honey
Bun with a basketball clip.
Wilson basketball
top notchotch quality. Even getting both
of the baskets in just kind of, you
know, got it. It's so much texture and
the realism like it's got humans down.
Well, take this shot, man. more detailed
than Sora 2 packs in. Lil Bee's got more
Rick and Morty.
>> Finally, some action. I was getting
bored of the scenery. Morty, get ready.
These guys look like they're fresh out
of the academy.
>> Quick, I don't want to DIE IN A CARTOON.
>> SEE, MORTY, that's how you handle a
pirate situation.
>> Rick, I think I'm going to be sick.
>> Wow, man. The coherency. Also, whoosh.
>> Hero, you're on
Pokemon.
Light me here. You try to save me. Got a
stage,
>> man. Dude, what?
>> Dude, the way it like coherently moved
the ball around. I thought they were
going to just start fighting, but like
it it was like Poke Jam the full thing.
It was the full deal. I was not
expecting it to have that much intricacy
and detail. Snow Strider bringing GTA 6
to life.
Except it's Pixar.
Oh my god, my brain is exploding.
Robnock. This looks like Nuke Town
brought to life
destroying the mannequins. I mean, yeah,
real. Oh, this is Breaking Bad and Mario
combined by Rouck.
Look how good Walt looks.
Dude, not Elmo, bro. What? Oh my god,
this model is so much better than Sora
2. It just is, dude. What is going on,
man? Walt looks perfect. Freaking Mario
also looking perfect. I don't know who
this is supposed to be. Dude, what?
Basically caught up with generations.
I'm going to go check my own. Okay, my
aquatic scene came through. So, this is
basically 480p default settings. Oh, it
did the full 15 seconds.
Okay, it adhered to the prompt better
than Sora 2. I can say that for sure.
That was very, very good. His head was a
little weird looking, but I think at
720p it would have been better. I'll
give that one more play and then I'll
show you the Sora 2 variant.
>> All right, here is the Soratu.
obviously using me instead. FBI fish
inclusion though at the end. I mean it
it's good. It's still very good.
Sora 2 Pro which came out worse.
I mean, I think you could just tell
Seance is better. My crab gen also came
through. This is like 360° footage of a
crab with a jetpack and he's escaping
seagulls.
Okay, it did it. Dude, that is that is
totally better than what Sorhead 2
cooked up. Yeah, there's some I think
hallucination. All right, this is
definitely the front of the crab and the
jetpack's in the back. That makes sense,
right? Spin around,
dude. What even is this model? It's
fully coherent. Sort of 2 would kind of
mess up the crab. Best sort of two
generation I got.
Insane. Insane. All right, I'm going to
run some more prompts through as I edit
and then put them in the video. But wow,
this feels fresh. This feels new. This
feels like a model that can tackle any
task. That is nano banana level video,
folks.
Morning routine time. Toothpaste first.
Nothing special. And then moisturizer.
Yeah, I know it looks a little intense.
It's just some leftover radioactive
waste. Works better than anything from
the store. Feels cool going on. Kind of
minty.
Good morning everybody. Your boy Nixon
is hitting the zoo. The orangutans here
are tremendous. Nobody has primates like
this. Magnificent creature. Reminds me
of myself, frankly. Incredible content.
Smash that subscribe. Molting. They're
just molting. It's a molting thing.
Like, comment, and I am not a croo.
>> Hello, my friends. Richard Nixon here
bringing you another candid look at
America's great institutions. Today, the
zoo.
>> Is that really him?
>> Oh, come on.
>> Behind me, the noble panda. A
I am your mother.
I am the danger.
Openheim.
With that, I hope Sora 3 and Google V4
are going to crush Cance 2.0 0 because
competition breeds innovation and the
best models for everybody. Hard to
believe that we might get an open-source
level model at that quality level by
2027. For now, I just want to make
stuff. I just want to experiment. I'm
going to post my best clips. Share what
you make on the Discord. And I will see
you in the next video. Thanks for
watching and goodbye.